racontez-moi un peu qu'avez vous pensé
du du plan de déconfinement d'edouard
philippe vous êtes convaincu pour la
suite pour l'après 11 mai
malheureusement non pas du tout au début
ça commençait bien il a annoncé un plan
progressif prudent je me suis dit que se
passe-t-il enfin un peu de raison et
puis patatras
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ouverture des
écoles des millions d'enfants vont être
rassemblés dans des classes sans masque
sans masquer les enfants qui ont le plus
de mal à voir des gestes barrières alors
on nous explique que les français doit
être raisonnable ils n'auront pas le
droit d'aller sur une plage ils n'auront
pas le droit de se rassembler à plus de
10 on leur demande leur mais d'énormes
contraintes ils n'auront pas le droit de
se déplacer d'un département à un autre
et puis en même temps on va rassembler
des millions d'enfants dans des classes
pour faire bouillon de culture mais
c'est une honte je voterai contre ce
déconfinement c'est pas possible de voir
ça par ailleurs sur les tests rien de
précis une espèce de délire de
surveillance générale qui ne marchera
pas alors qu'il faudrait simplement
tester ce qu'ils vont aller retravaillé
pour que dans leur entreprise ils ne
passent pas le l'épidémie aux autres et
puis dernier point il faut davantage de
masquer ce masque j'étais un des rares à
porter dans l'hémicycle qu'on nous a
offert ce matin en arrivant à
l'assemblée
tous les français doivent porter un
masque il faut donc accélérer la
production de masse
enfin des choses simples et une usine à
gaz bureaucratique inapplicable
alors qu'il fait des choses simples il a
fait son mea culpa edouard philippe au
sujet de l'utilisation du masque et
reconnaît aujourd'hui qu'il est
important de porter ce qui n'était pas
le cas car mois ou deux oui c'est vrai
qu'on a beaucoup moqué
quand j'avais mis mon masque à l'envers
en début mars je l'avais bien envers moi
je l'avais mis sauf que il a raconté des
mensonges parce qu'il a dit que
il avait déjà un stock important est
qu'on ne pouvait pas prévoir mais bien
évidemment qu'on pouvait prévoir enfin
si on avait un stock stratégique il ya
dix ans d'un milliard de masques et il
en avait plus de cent millions
et d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres
gouvernements sont coupables de ça donc
en gros c'est toujours la même sauce et
on peut comprendre pourquoi les français
n'ont plus confiance parce que ya pas de
bon sens
soit c'est prudent le déconfinement je
le souhaite prudent pour pas qu'on ait à
nouveau confinement donc il faut y aller
pression démesurée mais à ce moment là
on met pas tous les gamins des écoles
sans masque dans du dans une petite
pièce
c'est une journée défaite complètement
dingos pardonnez moi d'être un peu de
l'emporter c'était pour lutter contre
les inégalités sociales
mais ce qu'on luttera contre les
inégalités sociales en renvoyant
l'épidémie dans les foyers des gens les
plus modestes qui vont mettre d'ailleurs
leurs enfants alors que les classes
favorisées vont garder leurs enfants
chez eux
est-ce que c'est rendre service aux aux
foyers modestes que de créer des foyers
d'épidémie
enfin cessé en quoi on rend service aux
enfants ont fait un déconfinement
progressif on commence à permettre aux
gens d'aller re travailler on rouvre les
commerces on rouvre la libre circulation
dans le pays
on demande aux gens de mettre un masque
on teste les personnes qui retravaille
et dans un mois on fait un bilan et à ce
moment là on rouvrira les écoles ou les
centres de loisirs parce que l'année est
finie scolairement on rouvrira des
centres de loisirs fait par les communes
avec des mesures de précaution je ne
demande pas le confinement absolue je
demande un déconfinement progressif sur
sérieux c'est tout on parle de tension
entre edouard philippe emmanuel macron
votre avis sur le sujet même si
président de la république a réfuté ces
faits rumeurs l'attention en tout cas
elle est dans le projet puisque on voit
que le premier ministre un programme
progressif et que le président lui a
imposé l'ouverture des classes et que ça
fait un mélange de chevalet d'alouette
et que ça marche pas voilà en fait ce
plan il est incohérent parce qu'il est
dictée à quatre mains les deux mains du
président de la république par démagogie
a réouvert les écoles le 11 mai et les
deux mains du premier ministre qui est
dans une démarche beaucoup plus prudente
et donc tout ça ne fonctionne pas parce
que c'est
il n'y a pas d'unité de commandement on
le voit bien il ya beaucoup de légèreté
absence de bon sens total nicolas dupont
aignan président de debout la france
donc vous l'avez entendu nicolas dupont
aignan qui est bien refusent de voter en
faveur de ce plan de déconfinement
annoncé il ya plus d'une heure par
edouard philippe le premier ministre
merci beaucoup
nadège nadège abderrazak en direct de
l'assemblée nationale